yeah well because
it's hard to turn down as a guy
if you could sleep with 20 girls at the
same time or or be strapped down with
one girl i can't
yeah where are most guys gonna pay i'll
be honest it was
maybe i don't know if i should say this
depending he's watching it [ __ ] it um
when lumbar x
broke up
and i'm you know like i said very honest
like i'm like this is where i'm at don't
believe it
i'll be honest there was a point where
you know a two-year relationship just
came out i was seeing six seven goals at
the same time i'll be honest and they
all knew they weren't new
but then it got to a point seven
where yeah it was two times like it took
away from my work of course that's
assuming like it's not worth it yeah
it's not worth it six how would you
juggle what's the hell did you do that
bro what was your conversations like the
most i've done was three
where did you meet how often okay i got
questions okay
how often did you see them and where
would you meet them would it be dating
apps or just in person uh both so most
people most people have dated because in
my industry like i'm meeting new people
all the time right all the time because
i'm working on set then i'm in rehearsal
and you're meeting new circles of people
all the time
um so
half i'd say was from that and then
honestly in the last
since coming out of that like that's the
most i've ever used dating apps
okay um
some of them was from once
so
how often because i'm thinking
like did they get annoyed because you
can't respond to them all the time
because clearly you're hanging out with
them too right
i just got questions it was it's what
was a day in your life like when you
were juggling you see one at 12 and then
until five and then the next one came
around at six you know that dear make
something going to see loads of girls
names
i think it was
i'm spinning the beans but you know i'll
be honest you know i'm an open book um
i'll probably see
them like
once every couple of weeks
and because i was only available once
every couple of weeks to them it's like
oh his time is very i don't get that
much time with him so when he's free i
have to see him
oh yeah okay how did you make something
how did you how did you um
how did you do
baby
how did you do players i say players lie
i never lied and nobody else there was
one or two girls that i was honest i was
like look i'm not really looking for any
serious and they're like oh i am that
this isn't gonna work cool so everybody
knew what the deal was right like i
would never lie like that but i'm just
saying it how it is you see if it was a
wednesday
wednesdays was free
i'm feeling like yo i need to go see
one of my links whatever yeah
and let's say all seven of them was free
which one do you go to yeah do you have
like a favorite did you have like a
favor
i just got questions
i've heard three four girl rotations not
seven yes you're a different breed
what made them stay what was you giving
them besides
you know what was she giving them
he must have been giving him something
fixing the pipes
yeah i'm uh i'm very giving i don't know
so is that are you saying that's what
made them stay
no but i think i think um i gen like
anyone who i get involved with even if
it's in a casual thing i enjoy spending
time with them that's important to me so
like i said i wouldn't just do that with
anyone yeah but what does that lack on
your finances
not much no really
one today
because you'd only invite them over late
if he said he got limited time
if i take a girl in a day i keep i
always keep the first date low
investment so it'll be like for a coffee
anyways i get that and mainly because
well first off mainly because she could
be one of those girls who just trying to
get a free meal but also as well i want
to keep at low stakes so we both feel
quite chilled because that's when you
get to know someone yeah that's very
true so as opposed to yes go to this
fancy restaurant
so i always kind of
and then if that goes really well then
i'll take them out on a proper date be
like oh let's go rolling then have
dinner and then have drinks i mean but
by that point i've already connected
with them to some degree i think first
dates are
underrated
like i think your first date can
actually give you
um
a good sense of who the person is i
think when people do like the whole
expensive restaurant on the first date
it's that you you you're not focusing
on the person it's like you're focusing
on the environment oh my god you took me
here oh it's amazing yeah is that true
if you i think i think first date should
all should always be more intimate no i
actually prefer
um like a coffee or i don't drink but
i'll get a pop you know yeah
um but because
if you're crazy i want to be able to
leave
if i have to do a whole dinner i'm like
this could go south i don't want to be
stuck here
sitting in silence and
also i don't know i'm
i'm kind of busy so it's like that just
is a lot of time
yeah no it's so true like my first date
i always like if it's in the summer
i like to go for a part i need to go to
the picnic i'll do a picnic oh yeah keep
being in the park i moved to sit there a
picnic that's cute
i love i like i love nature yeah i mean
i literally love sitting in down on the
grass and just having conversation yeah
and that's what i was talking like what
do i want like i want someone who i know
who i can engage with yeah mentally yeah
i don't know that if i'm just like oh
her dress is great or we're in this
fancy restaurant yeah i don't really
know i'm not getting to know you i want
to know if you can talk
yeah because it doesn't do anything for
yourself yes that doesn't do anything so
it's just it's just it's just uh
um what's that word
um
not material it is materialistic
superficial hello super superficial yeah
superficial yeah you're just looking and
like for instance what did you say paul
said she turned her
her phone to black and white because our
what did you say
oh yeah i did black and white mode on my
phone because the the colors make your
brain addicted to it yeah really yeah
you can you can turn off the colors it's
kind of annoying i'm debating if i'll
keep it but yeah so like
obviously usually humans human beings
brains aren't attracted to those things
yeah so it's like when you actually feed
in your soul rather than what you've
seen for your eyes it's completely
different yeah yeah exactly different
yeah
because you're already on the date
because you find them attractive yeah
that's one point
yeah
just a low stakes thing it was to be
like okay do we actually vibe as people
yeah hundred percent i prefer those kind
of first dates also i'll be honest if i
take a girl after dinner she doesn't
i'll always pay but if she doesn't offer
i won't take her out again really no i
don't like that i went on a date
it's so funny i want a date like in the
last six months right really good girl
attractive girl having a great time went
to eat
but she was a very high earner right so
she's used to
spending right so um
the bill came
and i looked at the bill i was like
alright cool so i did this literally i
went to go and get my wallet out of my
uh my
uh
my coat
and she took her phone
because the guy came over with the um
the machine
yeah i was like what the hell are you
doing
hmm and she was like oh um i'm sorry i
just want i said don't ever in your life
do that so you so that ah that pissed me
the [ __ ] you really hate that
that pissed me off yeah don't try and
emasculate me on don't try to masculine
do that let me ask you a question
[Music]
wouldn't you want your daughter to be
um
independent rather than
relying on a man
um
i mean yeah but you're on a date
and if i'm taking you on a date i'm
taking you on a date
don't let me take you on a date and then
try and pay for the day what do you
think i'm afraid what did you take me
for like i think i think you're 22 yeah
yeah i think this is a generational
thing maybe i'm 40. so i'm just like
don't take because my dad don't take the
piss
like he's like why would i let a woman
pay for me um on the first day but what
is that is that uh i'm a man don't pay
for me or is that uh you're a woman
you shouldn't pay it's never it's if i
if i'm taking you on a date i'm taking
you on a date that means i am paying
that means
i'm taking okay are you taking me on a
date yeah yeah okay okay okay by all
means take me a date but if i'm taking
my date
don't do that
before she paid for everything
listen i've been you've lived you've
lived a lot of life
being an actress in certain circles
you know what's interesting if a guy
like i actually i've split on dates
before um the first day
yeah actually
mostly like one time it was just the way
like you ordered the food and i was like
yeah whatever it's like it wasn't but
but if a guy didn't offer to pay i used
to always assume he just wasn't like
into me because i'm like a victoria's
secret model was here like you would pay
for her
interesting but but then i kind of
understood a little bit more how men
think like more like watching this stuff
and i didn't realize how many guys get
abused for food dates yeah
i don't know i probably wouldn't really
hold it against the guy i think
i always think that if
if a guy asks a girl out and they're
going to date if he doesn't pay
then i don't think he was raised right
but if she doesn't offer to pay then i
don't think she was raised right the
matthew has he quote
that's what he said and i was like
that's so [ __ ] true yeah
that is true
because it's